I see both you guys all the time on
Instagram and all these clips I feel
like I'm looking at two superstars it's
crazy right yeah I watch it all the time
do you guys know each other at all they
call a mad friend he doesn't have any
friends by the way that's funny you say
that Donald you say Matt friend doesn't
have any friends it's totally not true
why don't you go by mad virgin or Matt
Lucas
look at yourself Matt kisses his own
mommy on the lips that's what he does
such a dog he's such a dog this guy and
looking mad friends
why don't we try Matt comes his parents
well that's true we can look at coming
in pants we've came in a lot of pants by
the way and frankly I might be coming
only coming to a porcelain Bowl in a lot
of proposal I have done facials to many
Tupperware buds hang on a second Howard
I'm sorry to try man this is Barack
Obama and let me just say crazy
[Laughter]
foreign